good evening and welcome to the John F
Kennedy jr. forum I'm Maggie Williams
director of the Institute of Politics
here at Harvard and tonight I have the
honor and the pleasure of introducing
one of America's most dynamic political
leaders Governor Martin O'Malley earlier
this year
martin O'Malley completed his second
term as governor of Maryland ending at
least temporarily a 27 year career of
public service in 1988 the governor
became an assistant state's attorney for
the city of Baltimore
in 1990 he was elected to the Baltimore
City Council in 1998 he was elected
Baltimore's mayor and he won Maryland's
governorship in 2006 back in 2002
Esquire magazine named Governor O'Malley
best young mayor in the country three
years later time named him one of the
top five big-city mayor's while
Businessweek called him one of the five
new stars in the Democratic Party as
Maryland governor mr. O'Malley signed a
bill that made children of undocumented
immigrant eligible for in-state college
tuition understood and he signed
legislation legalizing same-sex marriage
both bills were upheld in voter
referendums a longtime opponent of
capital punishment Governor O'Malley
signed a bill repealing the death
penalty in Maryland for future offenders
he also chaired the Democratic Governors
Association from 2011 to 2013 but let's
talk about now the governor is mentioned
in the media discussed in political
circles and has ignited the interest of
many Americans as a possible candidate
for president of the United States and
I'll risk a prediction that he gets a
question on that tonight finally we hear
that the governor is said to be an
accomplished singer and guitarist
speaking for many I have to say we're a
little disappointed he doesn't have his
guitar with him tonight nonetheless we
are entirely pleased and honored to
welcome Governor Martin O'Malley to the
floor
Maggie thank you very very much it's
wonderful to be here with all of you
the weather's very nice as well I want
to thank you for turning that out a
little better than the four feet of snow
you endured this year huh you deserve a
good spring so look it's wonderful to be
with you and I want to thank you Maggie
for your kind introduction and for your
hospitality and also I want to thank you
for your kind review of my musical
abilities I offer the disclaimer
admitted just like in government I tried
to surround myself that with really good
people and but I've been asked to come
here tonight to talk with you all of you
about building an economy that works for
everyone and about the better choices
that we need to make together if we're
going to make that true as Maggie
alluded to all through college and law
school I had a band so I've spent logged
quite a few hours working and I put that
in quotes but in restaurants and other
establishments and through story and one
of these restaurants I noticed this man
who through his hard work managed to
keep the whole business going he was the
guy who was there early he was there
late at the end of the night he was an
immigrant
his name was Miguel and I remember very
late one night after everybody had gone
home asking him as I watched him sweat
and put out a tremendous amount of
effort hoisting kegs bussing moving
things all over the place I said Miguel
how is it that you can work so hard and
rather than answering my question how he
answered me very plainly why in just one
phrase and he said for my daughter our
national character is defined by a very
powerful idea
the idea the United States of America
offers economic opportunity for all and
as Americans we believe that no matter
who you are or where you were born your
hard work should pay off we believe as
Americans that every individual willing
to work hard should also be able to get
ahead that every American should be able
to provide in other words for a better
quality of life for their children and
for their grandchildren and this is the
powerful truth of the American Dream
that we share it is the core of our
national character it is the story that
has guided our economic choices as a
people for most of these 240 years and
these are the choices that built the
strongest and most resilient economy the
world has ever known we the people have
chosen generation after generation to
give our children a future with more
opportunity not less and together we've
strived in every generation to include
more of our citizens more fully in the
economic in the political and in the
social life of our Republic in other
words to extend and to make true the
American dream to ever widening circles
of our people this is both the moral
theory of our nation and it is the
economic theory of our nation
it is this inclusive theory of growth
put into practice that has made and
built the largest strongest and most
prosperous middle class that the world
had ever known it is the national story
of success that has made us known the
world over as the land of opportunity
there is no such thing in our country as
a spare American and I would submit to
you that impulse
that impulse that we share as Americans
to treat everyone with dignity and
respect is the same impulse that is
actually best for economic growth of the
sort that lifts us all you see the
economy isn't money the economy is
people it is the work the imagination
the grip the desire the skill the love
of family the creative capacity of every
person that actually drives our economy
and makes our country stronger this is
why signs that once read know Irish need
apply or no women or no blacks or no
Jews have become sad relics of our past
this is why the next generation of
Americans so universally rejects state
laws that discriminate against gay and
lesbian Americans the fact of our world
is this democratic nations are more
prosperous nations and it's not merely a
coincidence
people in democratic nations have the
opportunity to participate more to
innovate more to take more risks and
start companies and yes to drive
economic demand consumer demand through
their higher earnings and this
inclusiveness the robust participation
of more and more of our people is the
heart and cause of sustained long-term
generational prosperity in the United
States of America the American economy
the American economy that our parents
and grandparents lived and built from
their choices was an extraordinary
success I'd like to talk about where
we've been where we are and where we're
going in the economy that our parents
and grandparents built in sharp contrast
to what's happened across various income
levels
over the last 30 or 40 years in sharp
contrast to that from 1947 to 1979 every
income group of households in the United
States from the poorest to the richest
were able to increase their earnings by
at least a hundred percent in real
inflation adjusted dollars over that 40
year period of time all of that progress
was built on hard work expanding
economic participation and policy
choices that made sure that wages
actually kept up with increased
productivity of course all of that
started to change when we started making
different choices beginning in 1980 we
turned away from this tried and true
success story and we embraced a
different theory a new theory a new
story a story that turned out to be
false now whether we call that story
supply-side economics as President
Reagan its pioneer like to call it or
whether we call it voodoo economics as
President George HW Bush referred to it
or whether we call it trickle-down
economics as Americans who have come to
know it now call it the primary goal of
that theory was this to greatly
concentrate wealth and capital of our
nation in the hands of the very few and
what was the promised benefit of this
strategy for our country and for our
economy for the common good that we
share it was this that the very rich
once made very much richer would invest
larger sums of this newly concentrated
wealth and capital into greater job
creation and then our entire country
would benefit just wait they told us
concentrated capital and free markets
were far better than economic growth we
were told far better
for economic growth and we're far better
than wage policies for investment
policies or regulatory policies and the
actions that used to flow from those
common-sense policies in other words the
goal of a stronger middle class was
thereby replaced in the 1980s by the
goal of capital accumulation and capital
concentration poverty was no longer a
common enemy or a problem that our
government could even solve in fact the
new common enemy became our federal
government itself as President Reagan
famously proclaimed government is the
problem and for the good of our people
we were told our federal government
needed to be reined in needed to be
weakened needed to be removed from our
lives wherever and whenever possible and
over the next thirty years this
trickle-down theory dominated our
economic debates and it guided most of
our political choices and its three main
tactics were these number-one tax cuts
and tax policies that not only under
invested in our country and our nation
but grossly and disproportionately
benefited corporations and the ultra
wealthy number two the systemic
deregulation of even the riskiest
investment behavior in our financial
markets on Wall Street and three the
adoption of state and national policies
that were actually designed through
action and inaction to keep wages low in
order to make us more competitive now
this theory of course fell totally apart
with the crash of 2008 millions of
people lost their jobs lost their homes
lost retirement benefits and now
Americans all across our country are
actually demanding a better balance as
we gather here tonight wealth and
economic power in the United States of
America have now been concentrated in
the hands of the very few as
almost never before in the history of
our country the top 1% of American
society now controls more wealth than 95
percent of American families combined
after worsening cycles of boom bust and
bailout just five banks now control half
of the 15 trillion dollars in assets of
the US banking industry corporate
consolidations have now created near
monopoly concentrations in important
sectors of our economy our once
competitive American economy in the
1980s CEOs earned 46 times as much as
their average worker and today the
average CEO earns 331 times the amount
of their average worker bad trade deals
have sent American jobs and American
profits abroad and we are all paying for
these poor choices how we're paying for
it in lower wages and we're paying for
it and diminished opportunities for our
children wages in the United States of
America are lower now than they were
twelve years ago and this is the first
time that that has happened
this side of the second world war and it
is not good for economic growth
not when 70% of economic output comes
from consumer demand bonuses alone paid
last year on Wall Street totaled more
than what every American working at
minimum wage made in our country and now
concentrated wealth has accumulated
concentrated political power in the
halls of our Congress and also in many
many many of our state houses making it
harder than ever to get things done the
vast majority of us in other words are
working harder but we're watching our
families slipping further behind and
this is not how our economy is supposed
to work this is not how our country is
supposed to work and I know that there
are good many caring CEOs
people like Bertolini at Aetna mr. price
and others who are working on Wall
Street a lot of good people there as
well who would agree and who are
troubled frankly and they're saddened by
what this poor temps for the future of
the country that we love in the future
that all of us want our children to have
and it doesn't have to be this way so
how do we change this and how do we
reward productive investment again how
do we restore in other words a human
purpose to our American economy I
believe that we do this in five primary
ways first we must restore common sense
wage policies that strengthen our middle
class
this means that yes we must raise the
minimum wage and index it to inflation
so the minimum wage always stays above
the poverty line we must also raise the
threshold for overtime pay which hasn't
been raised since the 1970s so that
people can actually be fairly
compensated for the extra work that
they're doing on the job and so that
employers will have an incentive to add
new workers rather than forcing
employees to work longer hours we must
make it easier rather than harder for
workers to organize and to press and to
collectively bargain for better wages
wages that not only keep pace with
inflation but keep pace with the
remarkable productivity of American
workers and we must recognize that
policies that are good for women and
families like paid leave and safe and
affordable childcare are also good for
our national economy and for economic
growth because women succeed our
American economy also succeeds and
there's another important piece of it
and it is this when it comes to wages in
order to raise wages we must recognize
that immigration reform is an economic
imperative for our entire country we've
done this before and we must do this
again we have to build a path to
citizenship to bring 11 million
undocumented immigrants out of the
shadows of our economy and into the
mainstream to boost consumer demand to
create new businesses and to expand our
tax base thereby raising wages for every
one second second we must restore public
investments in the common good and the
future of our nation investments in
research and development investments in
infrastructure and investments in
education like universal pre-k and we
also need to invest in our public
colleges and universities to make
college more affordable for more
families the more a person learns the
more a person earns and we need to make
it possible for students to actually
refinance their college debt and their
college loans just like we made it
possible for people to be able to
refinance their their home mortgages
and we should make it the norm we should
make income based repayment plans the
norm so that young people whose passion
might be teaching or nursing or policing
to be able to follow their dreams and
also be able to pay their bills and
start families third we need to restore
accountability to our financial markets
they're important we want them to work
and we want them to work well but not a
single Wall Street executive was
convicted of a crime related to the 2008
economic meltdown not a single one
explained to me how it is that you can
be pulled over for a broken taillight in
our country but if you wreck the world's
economy you're somehow untouchable I
don't get that
we must charge and empower professional
regulators to penalize and prosecute
those who lie cheat and steal with
billions and trillions of our dollars at
stake
we must reinstate glass-steagall to
prevent giant banks from gambling with
our economy and our money and if a bank
is too big to fail we need to break it
up before it breaks us forth we need to
stop entering into bad trade deals I'm
for trade and I'm for good trade deals
but I'm against bad trade deals like the
trans-pacific partnership that hurt
middle class wages that hurt middle
class wages and SCHIP middle class jobs
not to mention making it easier to ship
corporate profits overseas look chasing
cheap labor abroad will not help us
build a stronger economy at home we need
to focus on making our economy
sustainable more circular and making
ourselves strong here at home that's the
best way for us to engage in trade all
around the world and fifth we must honor
those who have worked hard all of their
lives
and now find themselves approaching a
retirement that is anything but secure
we cannot grow our economy if we resign
a whole generation of our senior
citizens to living their golden years in
poverty so rather than reducing social
security or privatizing Social Security
I believe that we need to expand Social
Security benefits in summary the better
choices our national interest demands
are not radical they're not rash they're
not unproven choices they are the better
choices common-sense choices to which
many states like Maryland Colorado
Washington state Minnesota and
California are returning in Maryland we
put the primary goal of a stronger
middle class at the center of every
decision we made so yes we raised the
minimum wage we expanded collective
bargaining we passed a living wage while
freezing in-state tuition for four years
in a row and we made record investments
in education to make our schools the
best in the nation as well as investing
more in infrastructure and more in
research and more in innovation these
are the choices these are the
investments that made Maryland one of
the top States for upward economic
mobility for families that secured
Maryland the highest median income in
the nation and also since the depths of
the recession that gained Maryland a
faster rate of job creation than our
neighbors in Virginia or Pennsylvania
who were mostly trying to cut their way
to prosperity you see a stronger middle
class is not the consequence of economic
growth a stronger middle class is the
cause of economic growth
and we know how to do this we must
return in other words to our true selves
we must rebuild and restore our economy
from the middle out and from the middle
up when workers earn more money
businesses have more customers and need
more workers and our whole economy grows
this is why every choice we make
together in our democracy whether it's
wage policies or investment policies or
regulatory policies should serve the
cause of a stronger and growing and more
inclusive middle class we are Americans
and we make our own destiny we use our
talents our hard work our better choices
to build a better future together a jobs
agenda for renewable energy that to
match for the climate challenge a new
agenda a national agenda to rebuild
America's cities investments in
infrastructure and innovations and the
skills of our people that make our
country stronger so we can be able to do
more for our children and grandchildren
free markets free markets by themselves
do not create the generational wealth of
great nations rational hard-working
caring and patriotic human beings do the
future we choose for our children and
grandchildren as Americans is not a
future of less opportunity it is a
future of more we are standing at the
threshold of a new era of American
Progress and we need only the will and
the leadership to move forward to the
future we prefer thank you very much and
I look forward to talking with the after
we are going to open up for questions I
think many of you know the drill please
identify yourself and your affiliation
one brief question no speeches in your
question with a question mark okay so we
have a mic here there there and there
there's a mic there there's a mic right
there sir if you'd like a question my
name is John I'm a sophomore at the
college and my question for you is do
you think that a Hillary Clinton
presidency would be able to accomplish
this economic vision well John that's a
very skillfully constructed question how
can I answer that well well that'll be
that'll be up to that'll be up to the
American people the those of us who may
step forward to offer ourselves as
candidates something I'm seriously
considering myself I have a have a more
defined role and that is to put forward
our very best and terms of the ideas the
frameworks and the better choices and if
anyone believes they have the executive
experience the ability to bring people
together to get difficult things done
they should offer and then it'll be up
to the people to decide and we'll be a
better country for it
hello governor thank you so much for
being here my name is Jacob Morello I'm
a senior at the college and you
mentioned that one of your proposals
would be to expand the Social Security
program so I'm curious you know as of
the latest trustees report Social
Security is expected to run out of money
in 2033 and so expanding it would reduce
the life of that by up to a decade if
not more so my guess is that you would
probably propose raising taxes in order
to pay for this expansion you know on
the senior I'm about to enter the
workforce as our 1,600 my friends so you
know I'm curious do you think that
that's a good idea raising taxes on
working Americans considering that about
50% of the federal budget is devoted to
seniors and the federal government
spends every year $26,000 on seniors for
his they only spend $12,000 on children
yeah great question
look let me what when I was during the
eight years that I was governor and
before that as mayor the choices that we
made in some of them that I talked about
tonight we paid for all of them our
state had a triple-a bond rating I mean
every state has to balance its budget
and you probably see a lot of governor's
coming through and saying we unlike the
federal government had to balance our
budget every year yeah well we did too
but we had a triple-a bond rating all
the way through that and also made the
investments that allowed us to come out
of the recession sooner than others so
so no progress is sustainable if you're
not willing to pay for it and be
fiscally responsible I believe that you
can pay for this expansion of Social
Security and I believe we must because
once upon a time everyone was told you
had a three-legged stool for retirement
personal savings employer pensions and
Social Security well now people don't
have the savings and so many employer
pensions had been wiped out that most
people only have Social Security so for
the sake of our economy of making our
economy grow we can't have this sort of
bubble of baby boomers approaching
golden years in retirement the way you
pay for it I think is three primary ways
one you raise the earnings cap on
payroll taxes so that wealthier people
do contribute to Social Security it's
not called senior
it's called social security it's good
for our entire society secondly by
passing immigration reform and
opening-up a pathway to 11 million
people to live in the full light of
society and also to contribute to social
security that helps with the
sustainability of that program and then
the third thing is that if we go for
another ten years
with people earning less than they did
last year that would be a damaging to
our deficit our debt and also to Social
Security so these wage policies and they
then all fit together with them with the
solvency and extending the solvency of
Social Security so those three things
raising the threshold immigration reform
and wage policies that lifts up our
middle class allow us to make more when
we work harder my name is max liebe
second I'm a sophomore at the college I
want to ask you a question where are you
from I'm from New York City place yeah I
guess my governor is probably not
running for president but I I want to
ask you a question about campaign
finance so you're you're a lawyer and as
you probably know there's obviously been
a lot of anger about the Citizens United
decision but in fact the Supreme Court
decided long before that that corruption
in campaign finance can really really
only counts as quid pro quo corruption
which is why they've allowed for quite
some time in various forms on
essentially unlimited independent
expenditures so my question for you is
given that the Supreme Court has ruled
this would you support a constitutional
amendment allowing Congress to place
caps on independent expenditures and
perhaps more broadly do you agree that
the only type of corruption is you know
quid pro quo corruption where I give you
a bribe and you give me a policy I do
support the I do support the overturning
of Citizens United
I our state passed a resolution to that
could be wrong but I do support a
constitutional amendment to overturn
Citizens United I don't believe that
corporations are people
and there's a lot of good ideas that are
starting to bubble up from America
cities where you know we're actually
very forward acting and forward leaning
mayor's men and women have been able to
restore the trust necessary and and how
we govern ourselves so on there's also
some interesting so on campaign finance
reform I think we need to look at the
ideas that work that actually leverage
those smaller donations and multiply
them by matching them by some exponent
and I think that would all be a positive
move in the right direction to your
larger question about corruption and the
definition of corruption one of the one
definition of corruption is when special
interests are always able to prevail
over national interests and our common
good and unfortunately not unfortunately
the fact of the matter is because of the
choices that we have made to concentrate
wealth in the hands of the very few and
also to overturn spending limits
especially on independent expenditures
and the like and citizens united we've
gotten to a situation where the
accumulated capital is communic has
accumulated political influence and you
see it time and time again most notably
when I believe the effort I'd start to
lose track of the various times that our
Congress has attempted to shut down our
government but I do believe when they
were debating whether or not to continue
to fund our Homeland Security I believe
that forces from Wall Street at the top
of some of the biggest banks and trading
companies insisted on slipping in a
rider to that reauthorization of
Homeland Security funding that would
water down dodd-frank that is a trumping
of the national interest for the sake of
special
interests and I in this conversation
that we're about to have as a nation we
need to elevate the national interest
we need to heal our democracy make our
government work reform campaign finance
and and and move very quickly to
bipartisan congressional redistricting
commissions or we won't have the trust
necessary to make a great country hello
my name is Marcus Dennis I'm a freshman
at the college and a resident of Fort
Washington Maryland all right as well as
a good
Gonzaga graduate so it's good to see you
out there go Eagles do you know it so
just between you and me right it would
see nice to yes or no are you going to
run for the office the President of the
United States and if you're going to you
made the hard decisions to raise taxes
and fees in Maryland 31 times during
your eight years as governor and you
talked about a lot about funding your
different policies would those policy
you didn't raise taxes just on the
highest percentage of those income and
Maryland it was through all citizens so
would you do the same when you are
present United if you run for president
United States or if you were to say yes
to my initial question the that's a
compound question to the first to the
first point I'll make a decision by the
end of May I'll make a decision just
between you and me let me talk a little
bit about what we did in Maryland we
were very briefly not to get entirely
ship in the bottle with you but you'll
find other stuff online we did when we
when I defeated a Republican incumbent
governor and stepped into that trust for
you and your family we were facing a 1.7
billion dollar structural deficit can
that had been kicked down the road and
had accumulated so we had to tackle it
we tackled it early in a special session
and none of the choices were
individually popular in fact they were
all individually very unpopular the
three four primary choices that we made
were these we put in place a dollar tax
on cigarettes which allowed us to extend
health care before the Affordable Care
Act to about 300,000 feet
mostly children who didn't have it
before in Maryland the second thing that
we did was we raised the corporate
income tax by one percent which still
kept us in the middle of our of our
reach and in terms of competitiveness
the third thing that we did that we did
ask everyone to do was to pay another
penny on our sales tax which at the time
was five cents with no local kind of you
know piggyback onto it so which made us
the forty second lowest sales tax in the
nation and we did ask everybody to pay
another penny on that and with those
dollars we were able to invest in
creating the best public school system
in America recognized by Education Week
magazine five years in a row those
dollars went to equitable school funding
and the fourth piece of that fiscal fix
was we put in place for the first time
in Maryland a progressive income tax so
on that score we asked the top earning
15% of us to pay more and everybody else
paid the same or less that's eighty-five
percent of us and offset the impacts of
the sales tax on our most humble earning
households we raised the Earned Income
Tax Credit the state version and then we
went back and raised it a second time a
few years later so that's what we did we
just came through a campaign at home
where the Republican nominee for
governor beat my image over the head for
the 31 taxes and tolls I I raised some
of them were fishing licenses some of
them were bridge tolls that hadn't been
raised since 1972 but the fact of the
matter is in terms of percentage of
income our state has there are only
three states that have a lower state and
local tax burden than Maryland as
percentage of income so we focus on
prosperity and upward mobility and we
made and one of the things that makes me
a little different than some of the
governors that you see running around
the country nationally is we've actually
done these things in our state and we
succeeded
and creating greater upward economic
mobility for people along with raising
procurement goals and minority and women
business things and other things so
anyway that's what we did and and we
were the better for it but most of those
things were singularly unpopular
governor my name is Ben Bulger and I'm a
Harvard alumnus I think you would agree
I appreciate your talk on the importance
of the economy and a big important
aspect of the economy is capable
political leadership I think back to
when in democratic primaries Barack
Obama ran in a primary very contested
primary so did Hillary Clinton and also
Joe Biden and it turned out that someone
argued that Joe Biden became a very good
vice president Hillary Clinton became a
great Secretary of State if you look
forward to the future do you think it's
possible that Hillary Clinton could be a
good vice president and alternatively do
you think you could be a good vice
president I don't think I don't think
anybody actually runs for vice president
I don't think anybody runs for vice
president I think I think what we hope
though is that all of our public
officials have the humility to approach
these public trusts understanding that
they have a tremendous amount to learn
every single day I mean if there's
something that a great and a very
elusive commodity in our country right
now it's it's understanding and I would
I would hope that all of our leaders
would confess the fact that all of us
have a lot to learn and a lot more to
understand about ourselves about one
another
about this world that we find ourselves
the leaders of it a really perilous time
Rachele Brinkley from Quincy up in the
rafters from where Quincy Massachusetts
just wanted to thank you for your speech
he made many important points on the
economy on the financial problems so I I
would like to say I think on behalf of
many people I urge your candidacy on
this issue I think it's very important
like and also in respect to the physical
economy as well things like the water
crisis in California which i think is a
solvable Christ I think there are many
solutions that can be adopted but that
simply that that message hey thank you
yeah we didn't talk too much about the
environment or sustainability here
tonight if we if we look at the
challenges that we have on this planet
of finite resources as an opportunity I
think there are ways that we can that we
can face down this threat and actually
be a be a truly great generation of
Americans I mean the things that the
technology that we have the ability to
bring forward on clean water on clean
energy on renewable energy and and boy
the clock is ticking as you see the
severe weather across the country and
you see what we're facing in California
we we have to usher this era forward
wrap it in a prosperity frame and go
after it is the greatest business
opportunity we've ever been confronted
by thank you when I remind everyone
questions I need questions
hi governor thanks for speaking today
my name is Arjuna and I'm a sophomore in
the college I'm from Florida I wanted to
ask you a question that's not related to
the economy but to social issues and
I'll keep it brief I know that you
supported the equal marriage law in your
state and I wanted to ask how are you
able to reconcile support for same-sex
marriage with your religion or do you
see those two not coming into conflict
great question I was recently invited to
give a talk and you can find the full
talk online if you're suffering from
insomnia
I actually it's a serious question and I
enjoyed the talk and the time I spent
there recently gave a talk to the
Society of Christian ethics and there
their meeting with Muslim ethicists and
and Jewish ethicists and look the way
the touchstone beliefs that I have are
things that have been formed in me by
the parents and the household where I
was raised by my faith by the beliefs
that we share as Americans and as I have
sorted out my responsibilities and
strive to make the best decision and the
right decision for the right reasons I
think that there are three main beliefs
that I return to all the time
it is a belief in the dignity of every
human being every person it is a belief
in our own responsibility to advance our
common good even as we recognize that we
are people a diverse people of many
different faiths and third that we
understand that that we need each other
and that we're all in this together so
as we looked at the issue of marriage
equality in Maryland not only were we
able to pass it at the legislature but
then it was petitioned to referendum so
we had to have a much larger
conversation in our state and our
argument in s in it essentially was this
our closing argument in this
conversation and it was a touch-and-go
proposition and many people thought that
there were too many very religious
traditionally religious people in
Maryland to be able to pass this when we
did but this was the argument we made we
said that we should all be free to to
practice our faith as we choose but all
of us can agree as Americans can't we
that there is dignity in every child's
home and that every child's home should
be protected equally under the law and
so that's how I've I've come out on it
that was my thinking and ultimately
that's why the people of Maryland became
the first in the country to approve
civil marriage equality at the ballot
thank you thank you
hi mr. governor thank you so much for
coming today
- happy hello again so personally my
family came to this country six years
ago and I deeply care about
comprehensive immigration reform so I
want to ask for you specifically what
specific action would you take where
they on our campaign trail whether
you're elected president or maybe in any
scenario what would you do to push for
comprehensive immigration reform well I
believe that the way we campaign
determines how we govern so whoever the
candidates ultimately turn out to be in
the presidential contest in our party we
need to elevate immigration reform as an
economic imperative for our country this
should not be about satisfying this
group for placating that group for it
needs to be about us together it needs
to be about our national interest we the
people our economy our innovation
consumer demand would be best served by
passing comprehensive immigration reform
that specifically would involve a path
to citizenship for the 11 million people
who are here working hard love this
country and can make us stronger if they
live in the full light of our society
having that conversation nationally then
gives the would then give the next
president of the United States the
ability to act on that mandate and and
to never ever give up on it look it may
appear to us sometimes that this is the
most polarized divisive gridlock time in
our country's history we've actually had
worse and we've gotten through those
we'll get through this but only with
national leadership that calls us back
to our principles and to our values and
puts the best interests of our country
first that's what we need to do with
this and we need not give up because
I've been all over the country and I'll
tell you I don't find a whole lot of
people under 40 that deny climate change
or hate immigrants that's where our
country is headed our country is headed
to a more inclusive a more generous
and a more connected space and we need
to speak to it and govern to it
hi Governor O'Malley my name is Matt
Hale our I'm a first year in the joint
degree MBA MPP here at Harvard Business
School in Harvard Kennedy School and
born and raised in Ellicott City
Maryland so thank you I see real Jersey
to you no third person I've met tonight
from Ellicott City Maronites
are y'all having a convention yeah this
is it
so thank you for the service to our
state being here in in Boston this past
year I can't help but compare and
contrast Boston to our hometown of
Baltimore and they have a lot of similar
resources they have an amazing
waterfront some of the best universities
in the world the best hospitals in the
country but I feel like the cities are
on a divergent paths Boston's thriving
but potentially Baltimore has been
stricken with crime the past few decades
and has had population declines since
the 1960s I'm just wondering as someone
who cares deeply about the city and
wants to return how do we fix this Matt
Matt he'll our Matt the last time I was
here at the Kennedy School was about 13
years ago I was here with a man named
Jack maple I guess it was 14 years ago
then and Jack had been the deputy police
commissioner for the NYPD I shared that
with you because for all of the shows
the corner of the wire homicide that
have talked about how violent Baltimore
became and hey we did allow ourselves to
become really violent in fact we allowed
ourselves to become the most violent the
most addicted and the most abandoned
city in America in terms of population
loss more population loss actually than
Detroit in the 30 years leading up to
1999 that was our past and that was our
reality but when we started doing the
things that worked a better job of
policing a better job of policing the
police expanding drug treatment
intervening earlier in the lives of
young people at risk we achieved in
Baltimore the biggest reduction over
those next 10 years of part one crime of
any major city in America
and just about a month ago on the
Baltimore Sun there was an article that
said that not only is Baltimore's
population growing again but the
Baltimore has seen a bigger increase in
18 to 25 year olds choosing to live in
the city again than all but about three
or four other cities so we are headed in
a much better direction as a city we
still need some greater investments in
mass transit that's true we still need
more affordable housing we can be the
solution in our state to our Smart
Growth and sustainable growth challenges
as we continue to make our city safer
one thing and one thing that
Massachusetts and that the Boston area
has and it's incredibly not incredibly a
brilliantly successful Commonwealth and
state and the life science and the
biotech industry are not dissimilar from
what we have going on in Maryland in
fact over the last eight years if any of
my staff would say to me on the good
rankings that come out schools or
innovation or those sorts of things that
we came in second I always knew that
Massachusetts was the one that came in
first and that's cool I mean we like to
have good good friendly competitors in
building this new economy but the wanted
the colocation of so many top-notch
business schools in the Boston area with
your researchers is a great ecosystem of
innovation and entrepreneurship we're no
slackers on that and in fact US Chamber
of Commerce which hardly ever says nice
things about Democratic Governors named
us the number one state for innovation
and entrepreneurship three years in a
row but Baltimore's area has
traditionally lacked great business
schools we have one now recently started
the Carey School of Business at Johns
Hopkins that I believe has the potential
to grow into a great business school
full disclosure I am a visiting
professor there
thank you thank you Matt hi thank you're
speaking with us my name is Daniel
tostada I'm an MPP student here from San
Diego if you're curious great weather
like today so you spoke up a lot of
common-sense progressive fiscal policies
raising the minimum wage having
universal pre-k raising Social Security
benefits my question revolves around the
fact that I think that I would
necessarily increase government spending
if you were to run for president would
you campaign on reducing or eliminating
the deficit spending that occurs yes but
that I don't I what yes I would but I
think what the biggest deficits we
suffer from right now are actually
divestments in our own country that only
we can make I mean in the 70s for we
invested to the tune of about 4% of GDP
into you know the non-defense
discretionary spending namely
transportation education research and
development that 4% is now headed to
about 1.5 percent the biggest challenge
we face is an economy that lacks
consumer demand wages that are declining
and public investments that have not
kept pace with the demands of a 21st
century technological economy so on some
of these things we're going to have to
do more not less and that's and that's
the fact of that's the fact of the
matter but as our economy grows that
also allows us to bring our deficit and
our debt down in fact I mean no
president has has achieved smaller
levels of average annual spending
increases than President Obama over
these last seven years but part of that
has been achieved at the expense of an
economy that could be growing faster and
a country that could be doing more
especially with its people who are
underemployed and under skilled for the
opportunities that we're creating now
you got to do both man it's all about
balance
you have to be fiscally disciplined you
have to be able to balance budgets but
you also have to be smart enough to know
that India and China are not going to
make these investments for us only we
can do this and and we have the ability
as a people to do it and it can be done
in a fair and progressive way Thanks
thank you so much governor I'm Lilly
Valona
first year here at the college and my
question is a little off the beaten path
excuse me off the beaten path but I
think it's worthwhile to expand the
typical political discourse that we
usually engage in there on the edge of
their seat it's not me it's not that
exciting so you talked in your speech
about you know economic basically ways
to level the playing field for those who
have been excluded in one way or another
by our economic structure so I'm going
to include more people more fully yeah
exactly
so I'm wondering if in the tradition of
of economic reparations for those
japanese-americans who who were unable
to work and earn money while they were
in internment camps during World War two
and so that those economic reparations
were paid out an average of $20,000
would you support and you can say you
can explain theoretically or in
actuality would you support reparations
for those Americans whose families were
enslaved and thus we're not able to keep
the you know the fruits of their labor
essentially and then whose work did go
to build our nation but were
economically excluded and yeah yeah I
don't I don't believe I would support
that Lilly but what I do support is
building up a stronger country for
everyone what I do support is building
an economy with the human purpose that
allows everyone to be included
regardless of where they're born and
what zip code they were born into and
and so I support those things and I
think the way that we the we honor and
the the suffering and and the pain and
the death of so many people whose hard
work built this country is to make our
country stronger and better more
generous more compassionate more
appreciative and understanding of of one
another thank you very much thank you
all right mr. O'Malley I'm Christian
newest I mean remember I wrote you a
letter or an email
supporting you and asked you to run for
president for president of United States
you say you owe me you say they can make
that decision at the end at the end of
May yes sir at the end of May
yeah good luck I support you thank you
thanks a lot
because what boy okay boy
by the way I've been to Maryland and
Annapolis to visit the Statehouse did
you like it I did very nice very
beautiful thank you
George Washington liked it too oh yeah
oh yes yes hello governor my name is Dan
I'm from central New Jersey my question
is since we've you've talked a lot about
building a better economy for the middle
class and you're a former mayor and a
former governor how would you approach
foreign policy issue matters of foreign
policy from that background yeah thank
you great question
yeah look I believe that America has an
indispensable role to play in this world
of ours and I believe that we do that
best not only for the world but for our
our posterity when we engage with our
neighbors around the world consistent
with our best principles and our best
values we do that in two ways
I believe that we do that by making
ourselves stronger at home because the
rest of the world looks at what we do
rather than what we say and that's why
this cause of creating greater
opportunity and building up our middle
class is so very important to our
credibility around the world and this
system that we believe in of government
and respect for individual rights the
second way that we do this is I think
that is we have to move out of the old
story of the United States
the old story where the world was world
politics and foreign policy was
determined by giant super powers and as
a superpower we need to engage in a new
age of collaboration with like-minded
people around the world for the against
the common threats to our humanity what
does that mean what am I talking about I
mean that we need to become much more
far-seeing we have to recognize that
change is happening more rapidly in this
world especially with failed
nation-states and asymmetrical warfare
and the like and we have to be able to
be engaged and looking over that horizon
developing relationships with new and
emerging leaders in the next generations
of of countries that may appear to be a
threat to us today but have populations
the majority of which are under 30 today
as well and whose opinions and our
relationships with them can be forged
and changed if we deploy not just our
military power which is considerable but
understand that from the power of our
principles we also have the ability to
deploy our economic power our diplomatic
power and yes our considerable healing
power that makes us respected in this
world and allows us to anticipate change
so that it benefits us here at home
rather than threatening our children's
security so as I approach that's how I
approach it I've led trade delegations
all around you know to places all over
the world I've met with heads of state
and other countries I've found as John
Kennedy himself said that the the
reassuring fact that human nature is the
same the world over
and I've also spent a lot of time
working on homeland security and
preparedness here at home so one of the
keys that you develop as an executive
whether its mayor or as governor there's
also a very very important skill for
commander of cheat and in chief whose
job is to keep us all safe and that is
the ability to interpret and take in a
lot of different information and be able
to make the best decision at the time
because a lot of times the failure to
make a decision only makes the problem
worse and I think most people that have
been mayors or governors understand that
thank you okay last question
I don't know yesterday hundreds of
thousands of workers and Democratic
primary voters marched across America to
support a $15 minimum wage no candidate
has supported a numerical target would
you come out in favor of the $15 minimum
wage if not what specifically would be
your numerical target for the minimum
wage what would the policy be yeah I
support a $15 minimum wage
and and I believe what you're seeing
happening is that metropolitan areas
like Seattle or in our own state I mean
we raised our state minimum wage to 1010
that was the farthest I could push it
and still get the consensus to get it
done but Montgomery County raised theirs
to I think twelve eighty Prince George's
where's my friend from Fort Washington
Prince George's raised theirs to twelve
eighty as well eighty percent of our GDP
growth comes from Metro economies and
you're going to see I predict in the
years ahead
more and more metro areas raising their
minimum wage and rather than that
hurting their economy it's going to fuel
economic growth greater consumer demand
and make their cities in their metro
areas stronger economies and so that's a
microcosm of what we need to do and once
they show that it's successful it'll be
easier to return to what Democrats and
Republicans always did not so very long
ago which was to make sure that the
minimum wage always stays above the
poverty line so that nobody who works
hard has to raise their kids in poverty
thanks for the last question thanks